i was actually quite looking forward to
the olympics in tokyo because i thought
that you know the conversation about
trans women and sport
uh was going to get a bit of a different
perspective on it when you see the
visuals of active competition
we're not sure if they're going to go
ahead uh do you think
stuff like that will start to bring it
to to the four to people that this is
more than just about kind of respecting
people's pronouns there's an actual
real-life consequence to some of the
stuff
i hope so you know when i saw that um
there were trans athletes that were
going to the olympics i was upset
because you know i've taken a lot of
heat for this but i'm not someone who
supports trans women in women's sports i
think that almost all of the time it's
highly unfair um i think that that's
just a very simple biological reality
that biological males have
just a list of advantages even if they
are on estrogen
um however then i kind of like i kind of
agree with you i was like well maybe
it's a good thing because
the overwhelming amount of people who
argue
in defense of trans women and women
sports they have a completely different
picture in their mind they probably
don't even know any trans people they're
just trying to be virtuous um it's an
issue that they just want to be
nice about frankly they don't want to
hurt anyone's feelings so they do
support it however there are just
stunning visuals i'm sure you guys have
seen them they're just like the best
pictures
that are almost a parody of like
trans uh track
what's the word people who play track i
don't know competitors trans athletes
okay trans athletes whatever um clearly
i don't know anything about sports uh
like just
looming over their biological female
competitors like
beating them wiping them the [ __ ] out
and it's like how can anyone look at
those pictures and be like oh yeah
that's fair like it's a joke um
you know so
again that's one of the things i get the
most hate for that i don't support it
but i don't i don't really see why being
included in sports is a human right it's
not like you're being denied housing or
food or a job it's it's it's sports
it's a very good point blair do you
don't you think the problem is is that
most of the people who watch this will
share your point of view and they will
have complete empathy for your position
and will want you to live as full of
life as as possible and for you to be
happy as possible but they don't feel
that they can say trans women shouldn't
be
in female sports because that's a way to
get ruined cancelled have your career
shut down etc etc
absolutely i'm trans and i get attacked
for it so imagine if someone who isn't
trans is saying it you know what i mean
uh
but i do find that
most people feel that way like
because i've done videos on this topic i
suddenly have people reaching out that i
know in real life that aren't political
at all that don't have any
you know necessarily political
persuasion who are like
i've never been able to say it you know
i have people who
play sports like good example
my mom called me and said that my nephew
had two trans athletes playing in i
think it was like tennis or something at
their high school
and that they're just kind of like
demolishing everyone and no one's
allowed to talk about it like this is
just something that
people tend to suspend their knowledge
of how the real world works to argue in
favor of um which doesn't work
and you say it doesn't work but
eventually you can suspend your real
life knowledge of the world but
eventually the world is going to come
and slap you in the face as i've found
many times to my cost
right so that's why are you coming out
that's why i'm actually excited about um
those athletes going to the olympics
because i think that when people see
that uh juxtaposition
um like laurel hubbard for example you
guys know who that one is like
come on
like
if you want to talk about like track and
maybe baseball or something it's like
okay let's have the debate but like
weight lifting something that's
completely upper body driven and
completely like come on it's so obvious
but you know
it's it's one of those things that i
think people have to see to have their
minds changed about blair and you
alluded to the fact that this issue is
political and the truth is i guess we
probably wouldn't be talking about it if
it was if it wasn't a constant
thing that was
talked about in the political way why
can you explain this to me why is this
issue political at all
well because i think that um
transgenderism has become
a political issue which it really
shouldn't um i always argue in favor for
the fact that it should be treated as a
medical a neurological
issue
completely
um
but there is this movement to
demedicalize what being trans is to say
that you don't need gender dysphoria to
be trans to say that you know there are
no biological differences between male
and female which is a contradiction for
why they keep allowing and pushing for
underage children to get surgeries but
um
you know when you remove any
meaningful way to diagnose something
all you have left is the politics of it
and
that's what's unfortunate that there are
real trans people who are who have found
themselves becoming this political
football being thrown back and forth
between these two sides that
frankly both sides always get it wrong
uh
so you know
maybe it's a pipe dream maybe it's
impossible but we have to attempt to
de-politicize the issue we have to
attempt to
regain control of the narrative that it
is a medical issue in my opinion because
that's historically how it was always
treated you know there was a time before
this hyper awokeness that you know maybe
not everyone really knew what being
trans was but everyone kind of had this
um
underlying knowledge in the back of
their head that there are some people
that want to be women and some people
that want to be men when they are not
and that those people have surgeries and
have hormones and that it's like a
medical thing
um and frankly
i find that things were much less fiery
heated and contentious when that was
sort of the overall consensus that i was
like oh yeah it's a medical thing some
people do even people thought it was
weird they saw it as that
now it's become this hyper political
issue that is just toxic for everyone
and it is toxic for everyone do you
think part of the problem is and you've
alluded to it earlier in the interview
saying that you know people want to do
the right thing do you think people are
conflating the gay rights issue in the
early 80s and what the struggle that gay
uh the gay people had to trans people
and in 2021 and they just don't want to
make the same mistakes
really i think that that's part of it i
think that there's this
need to be on the right side of history
um whatever the current right side is
perceived to be
or a correct side i should say
um
and yeah it's just we live in an
environment where if you are not seen as
1 000 accepting 1 000 on board with the
current narrative and in terms of being
progressive
you almost can't even live in polite
society even in red states even in
places that maybe there are more
conservatives because these major
corporations that employ people you
don't have the freedom to say how you
really feel about things even if it is
something as
you know i don't think it should be
controversial at all to say that sports
should be you know segregated by
biological sex but it's become something
that is
[Music]